That's all.
I guess I'll sit down.
I would just say it's going to be
a short introduction to the film.
I'm Julie Anderson and this is Bridgette
and Josh and the were with the plastic
oceans foundation and one of our first
missions of plastic oceans was to how do
we get the world to recognize
the problem of plastics,
the new understanding of plastic if
and its impact on the oceans and our
environment. And that first step was
let's create a film that is impactful,
educational and meaningful and can
be delivered on a global level.
And that's, it took seven years
to create this film. The film,
the full documentary as a hundred minutes,
you can watch it on Netflix.
And this way we've created different
shorts for purposes like this.
That's 20 minutes,
eight minutes.
And the idea is to engage people in
conversation, teach what informed people,
raise the awareness of this global crisis,
but also engage people on in a
conversation on what we do next.
Not just repeat the
problem as much as it is,
we now need to do something and
encourage people to do those solutions.
And it's not a one solution
problem, one solution fix, but it's,
it's going to take a
global community effort.
Okay.
Yeah. Um, you know, I would just to
piggyback off what Julie said is, um,
we not only on the global side of things,
we actually have reached to
communities around the world. Um,
we have the film now in 15 different
languages and we've screened it in over 70
countries and it's really amazing the
outpour of people that reached out to us
on a daily basis just
saying, you know, we,
we agree and what can we do to help?
So I think there's a lot of interest
out there and I'm also curious after we
screen it to get your thoughts on, you
know, how you see this as well. Um,
and I think that there's a willingness,
it's also making it more
accessible to people. So,
um, thanks y'all for coming out. Um,
I'll be curious after you see the film,
to hear your thoughts about where plastic
lives in your lives here on the Google
campus in Los Angeles and Venice.
I'm a ways that you can
help shift the mindset here.
And maybe with your families or on Pasta.
Bring this film to the,
again this is the film itself is supposed
to be form you onto the get us all
onto the same level of understanding
and then we discuss afterwards.
So I hope you enjoyed the film and
we'll discuss afterwards. Thank you.
And the,
it's how the foundation now what we
work on and terms of putting this out.
Our goal is to get people to rethink
plastic co the problem exists obviously we
all see it when we go to the, to the
beaches, we see it when we go hiking.
You see plastic almost everywhere at this
point and we know the problem exists.
It's how do we now start to rethink this?
How do we now take knowledge,
new knowledge that
plastic does not go away.
It doesn't degrade back
into the earth any longer.
It simply remains and the very first
plastic that was ever created still exists
in some form or another.
And so it's taking that knowledge,
new knowledge and getting our generation
to really comprehend that and start
reexamining how we use plastic.
Now teaching the young kids that this
is not a product that they can grow up
with any longer. It's a new,
it's a new understanding.
And that's what we mean
by rethinking plastic.
And we go with this film and with other
different types of film and media shorts
we go to,
we educate children on what plastic is
to get them to recognize plastic is not,
it doesn't go away and it's a
new norm to live without it. Um,
especially single use plastics. We also
go these films to take it to industries,
different industries and in spa encourage
each industry to examine what they're
doing and how they're using
plastic and how they can modify,
modify their use of plastic
and become industry leaders.
And the other,
and the final third component
initiative that we push is working with
governments and getting communities to
start to work with their governments to
start pushing these policy changes.
And it really comes in.
And with those three,
three components from education,
industry and policy,
that's globally,
it's is the way that we think that we
have to move forward to get that site
psychological shift that we
need for social change. Um,
I think
that's exactly right. And
just kind of adding onto that,
I'm, I'm more involved on,
I'm the director of partnerships,
so I work a lot with industries that are,
you know,
companies that are,
I mean,
you can think about any industry and
it's going to have plastic, you know,
you've got, um, beauty products,
I mean in tons of packaging
and plastic. Um, even clothing,
a lot of people aren't aware,
but most of our clothes nowadays,
especially the disposable fast
fashion clothes are made of, um,
there are oil based or they
have plastics in them. Um,
and I just don't think we realize how,
how much plastic is in our,
in our lives really. And I think
it's going to take, um, you know,
at least a generation.
And that's ultimately our goal is
to try and be a part of it, um,
through those ways that Julie
has mentioned. Um, but in,
in the work that I'm trying to push is,
is working with into those industries
that I've mentioned and try to get them to
be a part of it as well because you
can't just approach it from one angle.
It has to be like multiple levels.
Um,
but the idea is also to be able
to empower consumers or you know,
do you want to call it? Some people would
call it reducers. Um, meaning you know,
you, you're not a consumer.
You want to, if you,
ironically you want to buy something
that will help reduce the amount of,
for example,
plastic,
it's going to be out there taking a single
use plastic like a water bottle that
has an average life of,
you know,
12 minutes and turning it into something
that could be nine, 10, 12 years. I mean,
there are things like suitcases out there,
their um,
car seats made out of
these plastic bottles. Um,
you know, that, that that's an something
that maybe if consumers aren't aware of,
right.
It actually costs more money to buy a
product that's been recycled or repurposed
from that perspective.
Like call it a suitcase for example.
So it's sort of informing consumers that,
you know,
you guys have an option as well to help,
cause if you're looking at two suitcases,
they look exactly the same and
one's a little bit more expensive,
you're going to wonder what
am I, you know, why am I
going to invest in that? Um,
so it's, it's also kind of building that
awareness so that there's a shift, um,
in behavioral habits and
consuming habits to cause.
The reality is there is a lot of plastic
on the planet right now, especially in,
I mean there's just so many layers to
it. If you go to, in places like Asia,
there's definitely, you know, there's an
issue of portability of the water, right?
So that, that's why, you know, plastic
water bottles, some in some places are,
are you still need to be used.
But for example,
here in the u s why are we still
using plastic water bottles? I mean,
it's not only that they've done a study
recently and they've shown that the
water in those bottles have a much
higher level of, of chemical activity.
Because it's plastic versus
like tap water. So anyways,
I could go on for a long time but I'm
going to stop myself there. Uh, yeah,
you can't,
it again,
as she touches on you can go on and
on and it does become overwhelming.
But at the bottom line and brief,
we do have the power to change and
to create that change individually.
Uh,
reflecting on what you do,
your personal use of single use plastics
and if you wanted to go beyond that,
even getting your families of your friend
groups to start changing each of those
changes make a huge difference
once you work collectively.
And then that's what we're as
groups like plastic oceans,
we are collectively giving that voice
to each individual action and which does
create that bigger social change
that we're looking for. And you know,
every but people we get often,
what difference does it make?
If I say no to one straw, one
straw, it's insignificant.
One thing I say is it's
white. One Penny. He may not,
1 cent may be insignificant to one person,
but if you collected 1 cent from
everybody in the United States,
that's a three little over $3 million,
all of a sudden that those individual
changes that change become something
significant. And now you add that
to on a global scale. You're,
we're talking about a movement that
actually does create a new work,
new future for us and a
better positive future.
Okay.
Um, I don't know how much that I have.
Uh, y'all are covering it wonderfully.
Um,
what excites me is the power
of this film and the films,
the shorter versions that
we've circulated to, um,
get folks to communicate with one
another about what they can do.
Cause like we can come up with
a bunch of ideas. But, uh,
our power is getting this out to folks
like yourselves who are connected to
different industries and get you
all thinking about what you can do,
how you can collaborate with your,
uh,
with your colleagues or with other people
who you know about making some kind of
change. And even if that's just raising
awareness so that you can continue that
brainstorming together for
that collaboration for change.
Okay.
It's on that note.
We'll do questions.
One thing I wanted to add is that, uh,
June is going to be go Google serve.
Uh,
we already have a couple of projects set
up that are very much in line with the
kind of work that you do.
One is with chrome alliance,
I was trying to remember the name.
They actually changed their name
but they're still on our uh,
website registered as both sea change
foundation and Karma Alliance and we also
have the Biota creek cleanup projects.
So if you're feeling very motivated,
um,
I'm sure you are after that.
Um, then uh, definitely sign up.
We just had an email come out today,
um,
about Google serve and I know we'll have
some internal communication coming from
our own lax leads. Um, and the,
the website is go Google serve dash lax
for you to go look at the projects and
sign up for some of these projects.
And I hope at least next year we
can also set something up with your
organization as well. We were a little
bit late on the timing this year,
but next year we'll do that. Um,
if anyone has any questions, I'm,
I can throw things at you.
Yes. All right. Um, so I wanted to,
one thing including at this
office that we're getting, um,
presented as an alternative is
kind of the plant based plastics.
And I was curious what the story
is about the breakdown of those.
I'm assuming they're not 100%,
which means that that whatever
part is not plant based,
then it's not going to break down.
Is that roughly correct or, and, and,
and also I have this impression that it
requires some sort of industrial process
to actually recycle it or break it,
make it biodegrade,
which means that that makes it that much
more likely that it's just going to end
up in the same place.
So I just wanted to do
just on that.
So there's a couple folks
with plant based plastic.
There are the two types I think you're
also referring to. There's the bio,
the ones that are
considered biodegradable,
which do require a special facility,
a special processing to help it degrade.
Um,
the reason there is a lot of cons to the,
this product is simply because it
gets mixed with the current plastic.
There is no way to separate it and it
actually then makes it even more difficult
to recycle the plastic that the
processing that is in place.
And there are very few
cities that actually have the
biodegradable facilities in
place and it costs more.
So that's one of the cons in terms of
other plant based plastics that um,
the problem with those
is that as you mentioned,
they do break and they break
down in the same way in,
it can take decades and there is no way
and ultimately it does end up in our
landfills and ends up in water systems.
And you then have the same problem with
animals eating it where it then ends up
in their stomach where they can
potentially starve to death because of it
blocking their systems. So does
it at as much chemicals? No,
but you,
you still have all of the,
the microplastic problems and
the put the visual waste to the,
that ends up to surfacing on our coasts.
So that's why we go back
to single use plastics.
Do we really need to,
to create as much waste to begin with?
Can we just have a regular cup or a
reusable bottle instead of finding a new
way, a new material to create
the same amount of waste?
We're just creating far too much
wastes that we can't handle.
I mean this for focus on plastic because
it is such a ubiquitous substance
that's used,
but it is,
we use a lot of all types of materials
that we need to figure out how to handle.
Um,
thanks for asking that question Tom,
because that was one of my questions too.
But uh,
I,
I just kinda wanted to ask about the
actual effectiveness of recycling, right?
Cause like,
you know,
in La we have our blue recycling bins
that we can throw all our plastic and
metals and paper into. But it's just
this sort of magic been that, you know,
I don't know exactly what happens
on the other side. And you know,
I'm often left wondering with
some little bit of plastic,
like if I put this in the Bin,
is it actually going to end up in some
new product or is it just going to end up
in the landfill?
Right
here in Los Angeles,
we have the best recycling in the sense
that all there are seven grades of
plastic for recycling and there
is aluminum and paper and glass.
So, and it's rare that cities
have all forms of recycling.
So La is good in terms of having all
of these forms of recycling processes,
but only approximately 10% is actually
recycled of all of our waste and recycled
waste, the other 90% does
end up in landfill. Um,
the problem, it's really,
it comes down to economics.
It becomes cheaper to
make brand new material,
brand new plastic materials
than it is to recycle it.
Find a use for it and repurpose
that recycled plastic.
So it becomes economics. The second
reason is that there is a short,
there's a shelf life on recyclability,
so your plastic bags
or the cheaper plastic,
the thinner plastic water bottles,
you can only recycle them so many times
before they degrade to an unusable
material,
whereas you don't have that as much with
pure substances like glass and aluminum.
Thanks.
Sort of piggybacking on that question.
So you mentioned that you
work with governments, uh,
without opening a gigantic can of worms.
Um,
um, I'm not gonna, I don't know if
you want to comment on the current,
um, EPA, any of that stuff.
But my question is in California,
since we've been kind of at the vanguard
of a lot of environmental policy,
and you mentioned La has a
strong recycling program,
even though I didn't realize it was 90%,
that is actually not re recycled,
which is pretty depressing.
Um, what can we do?
What can we do as Californians?
What do we do?
Do we keep pressure on our leaders?
Is Does your organization have
any efforts to impact legislation?
Uh,
coming up that we should know about?
Um, maybe I'm not phrasing this correctly,
but I think you get what I'm saying.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I'll touch on it a little bit.
We don't focus a lot on policy.
There are definitely or more organizations
that focus on policy because there is
a lot of,
it becomes laborious,
but policy is much easier to create
change when more people are on board.
When more people start to demand it,
demand the change or ask,
start asking for the change at
the policies will change. Um,
and here in La we have the new big policy
changes in Malibu that is implementing
plastic free restaurants.
So I think,
I can't remember exactly now the number,
but it's over 50 restaurants that
it will no longer serve you tent,
plastic utensils,
plastic straws and
other plastic materials,
which is amazing.
The second thing where we have to,
where we're going to see where we're
going to have to push is the enforcement.
And what does one do if a
restaurant is serving plastic?
Are we going to call nine one one and have
them arrested? Right. Probably not. But,
so it really comes down to
the consumer to really say,
why are you have the straw,
why do you have the straw?
And it does make one feel like an eco
warrior going into a place and saying,
why do you have the straw? I demand
something else. And that would be,
we're always encouraging people to be
that ECO warrior and stand up to do it.
If not,
this is where organizations like us go
in and we put the pressure on them to
follow up and to use media,
social media to put that pressure on
them to continue in that direction.
And that does tend to follow, you
know, trends like that. Follow.
Great. Thanks. Um, can I
ask one more thing, um,
on the partnerships
front? Um, one thing that,
well like I feel like the tourism industry
and amusement parks and all, yeah,
you're all nodding.
That's every time I see that.
I'm just astounded by the amount of waste
in the lack of recycling bins around
and that kind of thing and
all the single use plastic.
So I wonder if there's any,
if you work with them at all.
And also with companies like Amazon
who are doing same day shipping.
And you know,
there's tons of waste around that,
but people seem to be using it more
and more all the time. So that's all.
I'll stop now. Sorry. Um, so no,
that's a great point.
And you know,
we're sort of slowly tackling
it one industry at a time. So,
but that is something that's on
our radar as far as, you know,
just if think about it means when parks
or venue spaces in general concerts, um,
you know, instead, that's
a ton of, of, of things.
I know of some venues that have throughout
the country that are saying they're
taking baby steps and
they're saying, okay, no more
plastic straws, you know, um,
but you know, there's, there's a
lot more that can be done and, uh,
that's a really valid point and it's
definitely on my shortlist, so, yeah.
Yeah.
Are there lots of, there is change. I
mean, there are people doing things.
You can look at events, music
events, big music events.
You'll go and you'll see more and more
often you'll see refill stations and you
go to airports,
you're starting to see them.
So these are the changes
that when you start,
when people are starting to use them,
they're starting to put more of them
in there and it may be the problem is
overwhelming if you look at all
of the different levels of um,
problems that there are,
but on the, on that change,
don't underestimate the power that each
of you have in order to create that
change. Putting on refill stations in
each office makes a huge difference.
If they stopped selling,
if every office in La would stop
buying individual water bottles,
plastic water bottles,
it makes a huge difference.
Getting rid of the plastic bags
and starting to be reasonable.
These make big difference.
And companies start to recognize
these trends and they create the,
the new materials, the new products.
And that's where the change comes about.
And it,
the consumer has a,
a huge amount of power when it comes to
how you spend your dollar and they will
make it so they will start delivering
what you want. Um, because of the,
well they want your money. So I mean don't
underestimate each individual problem.
And,
and this is where we as what we do in
terms of finding these partners who are
the industry leaders? Where are these
individuals, these small community groups,
what are they doing?
There are people that are in small towns
in Chile and Columbia and India that
are taking,
they're making change within their
communities and then that voice becomes a
powerful voice within the
community next to them.
And this is how change comes about.
I use the example of smoking.
I'll often,
I don't know if anybody remembers, it
wasn't that long ago, 2030 years ago,
you could smoke on airplanes,
you could smoke in hospice.
Some hospitals in the u s
still like 20 years ago,
you could still smoke in almost
every restaurant and bar in New York.
You today I have a seven year old son
who finds it weird when he sees somebody
smoke a, it is a new norm. It is
not a norm any longer for him.
And that was within one
generation of creating that.
And it was one by one pushing the science,
getting people to understand the science
of second hand smoke and firsthand
smoke and smoking and little
by little policy changes.
People demanding,
I don't want us,
I don't want to eat in a
restaurant that smokes.
I don't want to go to a bar that smokes.
And those changes came about.
Policy changes came with that. And the
same thing can happen with plastic.
Um,
I think for myself,
one of the most exciting things about
this work is communicating with folks who
are in waste management,
who are in product design,
folks who are doing packaging,
um, and even folks who hit,
who are running programs at schools so
that the students can watch the film and
then have a brainstorming session,
ideation session where they get
to talk with the administration.
They get to talk with the folks who've
managed the facilities and considered all
the plastics that are a
part of daily life. Um,
and then cut out some of it.
Make that a big conversation.
The Diet.
There's a group of folks in Metro Manila,
Philippines who have been hosting a few
events for folks who are in the industry
of waste management of
material production there.
So that the folks who are at the top who
have that knowledge can get together in
a room and actually discuss
what's happening so that
everyone can be abreast of
it and then know that there's something
that they could affect later that they
could call up on another, send
out an email, speak to my someone.
We don't need that plastic anymore.
We can make or recycle this plastic in
a more efficient way he's use for some
kind of other product.
Um,
what's amazing is that I don't have
to know how any of this works. Um,
I could just help people connect
one another. Um, and magic happens.
I don't know what y'all
do here at Google. Um, but
you can make the magic happen as well.
I have a question, um, about,
uh, burning trash. So, um,
over the years, uh, there's been
articles about how, how much, uh,
Sweden Burns of their trash, like the
burn almost entirely all their trash.
And my impression of that was always that
that would lead to some pretty toxic,
um, off gases. Um, but
it's still touted as,
as environmentally sound as an approach.
Uh,
do you have any thoughts
about trash burning?
I mean I know reducing overall the amount
of trash in general is the first step,
but it's another step to deal
with maybe burning it, I dunno.
Is that a possibility?
So we refer,
the first solution that we
push is to simply refuse,
reduce your plastic use,
reduce your trash consumption and
producing tress producing there.
Then the second one we then called there
is all this trash that is in existence.
All the plastic that is currently
in existence. What do we do with it?
We don't know what we'd do with it.
So things like waste to energy
burning and burning the PLA,
burning waste, burning plastic. We
can we call these bridge solutions.
How do we get from what all this mess
that we've created until we can figure out
the perfect solution of I'm sure.
And people are working on technologies
to how do we re, you know,
keep the chemicals away
from getting into the air.
How do we burn it so that it's
efficient and it's not perfect,
but it does take care of the mass amount
of plastic that is in the environment
that is not going away,
that is degrading.
How do we control that before it
gets out of even more out of hand?
Right. Yeah. I just want
to jump on that. Um,
I think that it's easy to see when there
is something toxic around burning trash.
It's not very sightly often.
Um,
but when one considers the alternative
of putting it into a landfill site,
which then leeches,
because often landfill sites aren't very
well insulated from their surroundings
or end up in the oceans.
It's really not a bad alternative.
And that's not to say that there's like
a good one that like if we have a bunch
of garbage, we have like a solution that's
going to work well for everyone. Um,
but I think it's a pretty
viable alternative if it
creates energy and heat for
places that can reduce the need for other
fuels and keep stuff from getting into
the ocean, getting into food for not just
ourselves, but all the other animals.
Yeah. Don't we just send it to
space? Isn't that the latest thing?
Yeah. And then it can go
through our satellite dishes.
Anyone else have a question?
That's an impressive,
do you have any success
stories with businesses or
industries where you like you
okay.
Like an example of a big change?
Yeah. Um, actually we
worked with the UN a hotel
association in Thailand. Um,
it was last year. Uh, they reached
out to us and they said, listen,
we want to work with you guys
and we want to basically,
it's an island in Thailand
called Paquette. And um,
islands are always tricky because it's
hard to manage all the waste, you know,
in terms of logistics and transportation.
So they came to us and we worked with
them and we help them create like a,
a workshop that they used, um, with,
I think they're up to about 74
different hotels that are members of the
association.
So they took the workshop and the 20
minute film that you just saw, um,
we, they helped us in getting
into a, the subtitles tie,
subtitles and those two things.
They went around and gave a workshop
to the different members of the hotels.
Then asking them to,
you know, first of all,
think about all the plastic that they
have in the hotels and how they can go
about reducing that.
And that does sort of led to a whole
movement where basically they also,
we advised them to do a cleanup,
um,
which every year there's
international coastal cleanup day,
which is on September, I think
this year. It's the 15th. Um,
and the,
they got so much interest in it.
Basically they had that,
the local government,
the tourism board at the u s embassy,
um,
and others that all got on board and
came out for this huge beach cleanup.
And as a result of all of that activity,
they actually now have an upcycling
program, uh, with a Spanish company. Um,
they're called ECO health.
And so I would say that was probably
the first real big in terms of numbers,
in terms of just awareness and really
getting entrenched in an industry that
really,
really a tourism and travel is
probably one of the biggest offenders.
Right. So I would say that that was our
first big home run for me at least. Yeah.
And it started off small again,
we went in there to educate internally.
Some often within the industry they don't
understand how much waste there can to
me.
But by educating internally,
starting off with a couple of hotels
that did expand to the 75 which they are
now all part of the UN clean seas program,
which is now taking that same education
program and bringing it to other hotels
and other countries that are part of the
UNC Clean Seas Program, which this is,
that's that trickle down effect of
starting in one small island and Thailand.
And now it's being brought globally to
where other hotels are starting to listen
and how are they,
and it makes them question how are
they managing their waste internally?
How much waste can they
really can they know reduced.
And a lot of times that it becomes a cost
savings to them by just re looking at
the,
the plastic products that they offer.
Yeah.
We have time for one more question.
Um,
otherwise we'll just wrap up if
everyone is satisfactorily depressed.
Um,
one what,
one thing I wanted to say about the
beauty products and how that ties into the
hotel industry is,
um,
I stopped using any of the little
freebie containers at hotels.
I bring my own,
I have my own reusable three ounce
containers for hand cream and shampoo and
conditioner and I bring those with me.
I bring my own soap with me.
These are some steps that you can
take in your own personal life.
Sending a message that says, I'm
not using that. I'm not touching it.
I'm not taking it home.
I'm,
I'm going to leave it there because
I don't need that. Like, I can,
I can take care of myself and I don't
need, it's nice if you forget your stuff,
but, um, it's just something
to keep in mind. And then here,
like in our micro kitchens,
we have all these drinks that
are in plastic containers. Um,
it'd be nice if they were all like
Snapple in glass bottles with metal lids,
but they're not.
So just remember the impact you're
having when you take one of those.
And thanks very much to our guest
today was a real pleasure. Yeah.
And just one thing, I too, as
we obviously as a collective,
we grow.
So if you could share plastic oceans,
follow us on any of
our social media sites,
go to plastic oceans.org and you can find
more information of things that we're
doing around the world
and tell your friends,
share with people about plastic oceans.
Because the bigger we become and the,
the further our reach,
the more impactful we are collectively.
Thank you.